hey Mitch hey Greg what do you call a
nosey pepper I I don't know jalapeno
business hello and welcome to the first
episode of the lab a new series here on
ASAP science where we take your
questions and turn them into experiments
so we can experience science firsthand
my name is Mitch and I'm Greg and we are
ASAP science and don't worry the
animated videos are still going to be
coming out every week but on Sundays
leading up to the new year is our first
series of the lab so tune in on Sundays
and Mitch what exactly are we doing
today so today we're actually looking at
the science of pain and we're gonna
start out by having a lot of spicy
peppers to understand why spice feels
like pain and then we're gonna be
putting our hands in some really cold
water and see it's swearing can actually
help with pain and finally we're gonna
be getting electrocuted to talk about
the anticipation of pain and how awful
that is you're gonna be good at this
no I'm like so weak okay I'm the weak
one of this group you've got red hair
jeans oh you know I can like handle
anything yeah they're all gonna be
challenges by the way so should we just
should we just start yeah let's do that
all right first step we have our spicy
pepper challenge we've ordered these
peppers from the least spicy to most
spicy and then we have a list of facts
so every time we bite a pepper we have
to spew off a spicy pepper fact and this
is the hottest pepper in the world to
California reverse so we're really
excited about this one hopefully we're
not gonna protect I'll bomb it on the
camera and the first person who grabs
this milk for release relief loses the
challenge so are you ready ready all
ready spicy peppers excite receptors
that usually respond to heat and these
are known as nociceptors these
nociceptors respond to temperature
extremes oh my god in fact early on a
mechanical stimulus but they can also
obviously respond two chemicals
I want to spit it out and drink mine now
big when you eat a hot pepper like this
one you're gentle nervous system gets
very confused bring it capsaicin is the
active ingredient hot peppers which
stimulates the nerve to respond to my
increases and it's then juice that goes
to the brain that it's warm and that is
an intense stimulus which causes this
burning sensation
should we just have the milk I'm so
white like I miss Owen right I don't I
don't think I can do this it's getting
worse I can't remove it
my glasses are huh okay I quit
okay oh my god I feel sorry just drink
your milk no that is a ghost pepper be
careful man no signal creates the same
physical reaction to heat that is what
includes vasodilation sweating and
flashing I feel taking everything here
uh-huh and that's it
you sweatin you flush and your vessel
dies my friend my hand I'm sweating
sweating okay I'm gonna read my other
fact because I already lost my right
hand English I judge my okay
don't don't touch it more go wash your
hands
we're milking my haha no okay
go wash your hands or head
it was interesting one researcher
actually gave them rats spicy foods to
see if they would actually like it and
it turns out humans are one of the only
animals in the world that will choose to
eat spicy things
I'm literally drooling choosy spicy
things over stuff that actually isn't
spicy so how do you feel explain to us
how you feel like a fool for saying like
I'm so good at pain okay Mitch so why is
no cupful for us well so water is not
helpful because capsaicin is actually
hydrophobic so the water doesn't really
do anything except swash it around all
around your mouth whereas the milk
actually absorbs it brings it down to
your stomach and actually is a chemical
reaction that makes it feel a whole lot
better so avoid water stick to meal and
also the relief that you feel when
drinking this milk
okay so pleasure centers of your brain
which is why this feels so good right
now
and why people go back to spice even
though they know it's awful also I'm
gonna give up on coffee ghost pepper
every morning
yeah I'll be away for a 24 hours so pain
actually is something that is used to
protect your tissue from damage so for
example if you touch a hot burner your
tissues getting damaged immediately and
you feel the pain immediately but some
things actually take more time to feel
the pain so to elicit some slow pain we
have these buckets filled with ice we're
just gonna put our hands in them to see
how long we can last but the one caveat
being that Gregg is allowed to swear and
I'm not yeah you better believe it okay
are you ready for more pain I think so
Kai time to roll up and put it review
the exact same time to be a scientific
accurate as possible
all right ready 3 2 1 oh okay so oh my
god I study actually found that when
people were allowed to swear they were
able to keep their hands in ice water
for on average 40 seconds longer it's
because it actually releases in your
brain the fight-or-flight response it
releases adrenaline and you feel a lot
better holy a pigeon one interesting
thing is how when you swear too much you
can actually overuse that now you can't
anyway I'm actually in so much pain well
I'm feeling great fingers but oh really
oh good oh actually like hurts
are you seriously holding it I am that's
crazy but maybe my hands can it pull out
and like Miley like anytime that's my
hands gonna fill me in here look one
weird thing was that my body we actually
like heated at my face and body felt so
hot when that was happening I think it
was just like a fear response I was like
I'm gonna lose my hand
okay I have you feel like when you come
in from the kitchen a nice bunch of
items
well Greg one challenge number two as
well I go one we have one thing that
we've learned from this is that swearing
is great
okay so it is time for a shocking
experience they say that the actual
anticipation attendeth anticipation of
pain can actually be worse than the pain
itself how does it work I don't know
so we've been given this ball and
apparently we stick this key in and it
starts zapping at random intervals so
also it says on here this product emits
electric shocks keep out of reach of
children under 14 it may interfere with
the electrical devices such as a
pacemaker and do not use this if you
have a heart condition or any other
related illnesses and it says in all
caps this is not a toy we have to hold
the ball while we're reading the fact
and as soon as around we can pass it off
and the other person has to finish the
next fact we're playing two three right
yeah yeah this person who gets three
loses three shocks yeah I'm I have
really bad anticipatory like fear so I
know you have to go first cuz I want to
see you know go okay is it lame oh my
god is okay okay
studies have found that both meditation
and exercise can reduce or modulate
feelings of pain oh don't make it out oh
no it's good this does work oh thank you
on that did you also get electrocuted
yeah oh so like six times I'm actually
shaking is a little all right the
placebo effect can work for pain if it's
high end in a 2008 study patients
receive painful electric shocks
afterwards Tencent till SIBO pill was
given to the test after which alleviated
pain for about 64% the participant a two
dollar fifty per seat belt operators
paid for 85 percent specifically chronic
pain can shrink the size you were brain
in a study of individuals who with
chronic pain could show up to 11 percent
let up oh you almost broke my laptop you
threw it at the screen of my lap I did
not have a choice I think I should start
yeah that's okay you ready yeah I'm
gonna get shot again platypus are one of
the few mammals to produce venom though
the venom isn't powerful enough to kill
human the pain is excruciating it can
last for a month
naked mole-rats don't feel the pain of
acid or the sting of Chili Peppers
no oh you keep the scientific term for
brain fuses
naked raw rats don't feel spice
fascinating shorten shorten batsmen okay
let's talk about anticipation that was
it's not as bad as I thought it was at
first but it is shocking no in the worst
part is when you get it handed to you
and you're like oh it's gonna come yeah
but then as soon as you do that shock
you're right it more you can just throw
it away my hand you didn't ever get it I
know you did I got your your your second
hand the electric you okay well okay so
winner of this entire game has been Greg
so we made it through all the pain and
suffering but it was all for the sake of
science and now it's time for this week
in science talk this week scientists
have started to discover how we actually
spend our time using information from
over 1 million participants scientists
found that we don't actually work more
than we did in the past we just tend to
multitask a lot more making our lives
seem more hectic you might not care much
about your poop but your brain does
neuroscientists have found that microbes
in your gut can affect your brain
development and also your mental health
known as the poop study scientists are
looking at how microbes affect a baby's
brain development so next time you're
changing a diaper cake a good look at
that turd
speaking of poo did you know that naked
mole rats actually eat each other's poo
but for good reason research has shown
that when underlings eat the hormone
which foo of a queen
the added estrogen in their system
actually prompts them to help take care
of her offspring let us know if you know
of any other news from this week in
science used a hashtag twist and we're
gonna put all the information to the
studies we just talked about below our
twitter and instagram handles are right
here which you can follow and thank you
so much for watching the whole first
episode of the lab we had a lot of fun
making it if you have other questions or
experiments you want to see us try on
this new series let us know in the
comments below and make sure you
subscribe to ASAP science we have a new
whiteboard video coming out this week
and we'll see you next Sunday for the
next episode of the lab see you then